le son des branches qui craquent
n'annonçait rien de bon quand je suis
casser ici donc il y a pas d'électricité
de la glace et vous aviez les
transformateurs qui explosaient et il y
avait des éclairs
[Musique]
1998 100 mm depuis hiver glaçons de
s'abattent sur le sud du Québec
près d'un million et demi de foyers sont
plongés dans le noir
3000 km de lignes électriques sont
tombés ça fait 25 ans après toutes ces
années le PDG d'Hydro-Québec à l'époque
n'a rien oublié
ses pilons lui semblaient quasi
indestructible
on n'a jamais parlé que ça ça pouvait se
fonder cette époque
dans l'esprit de personnes d'un enfant
qui est impossible autour de Lucien
Bouchard la cellule de crise s'active
nous avons invité docteur
Luc Boileau à ce moment directeur de
santé publique de la Montérégie il est
aussi en première ligne
au moins 28 vies ont été fauchées par le
froid les incendies et les chutes de
glace beaucoup de traumatismes des gens
glissaient tomber sous fracturés partout
tomber du toit essayer d'enlever la
glace sur le toit cette crise dit-il la
préparer en vivre une autre ou quoi
qu'un peu différente pendant la crise du
club on cherchait à regrouper les gens
ensemble pendant la crise pandémique on
cherchait à les isoler aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a pris beaucoup d'expérience
au Québec sur la gestion des événements
comme ceux qui nous surprennent au lieu
de gérer six semaines
ça durait une semaine
Hydro-Québec depuis renforcé son réseau
notamment avec des pylônes antichute en
cascade le verglas demeure tout de même
la menace numéro 1 depuis 98 je dirais
on n'a jamais arrêté de de
réfléchir là-dessus donc la stratégie
vers GLA elle est là depuis le lendemain
du verglotte 98 une catastrophe qui aura
coûté près de 6 milliards de dollars ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal